all right trippy
trippy where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
austin texas austin
tell me about your uh your family
growing up you had both your parents um
i didn't really have family growing up i
was born through
uh father mother 17 21.
mother was 17 probably 21 uh
hardcore [ __ ] crackheads
um
but did every drug under the sun you
name it i was conceived on an acid trip
um and born addicted to crack heroin
mess
alcohol basically i had to detox for
like
six whole months when i was born
so they had to keep me in the hospital
um
so i could detox and [ __ ]
um
okay curse of course okay
um when i was four my mom died of cancer
um
so me my younger brother
14 months younger than me uh
were taken um by foster care uh forced
forcibly um so my father had just
he had no choice in the matter like
being
addicted to drugs and you know
wife just died
living conditions were very [ __ ] up
um
i don't even actually remember living in
a house or
apartment or anything like that
um
we were just really bouncing around
really
um couch couch hopping and [ __ ] and then
uh
and when we were adopted uh
i guess we were it was
complete opposite side of the spectrum
uh
the the woman that adopted us was a
is a multi-millionaire [ __ ] uh
um what's it called uh
manager of uh edna insurance
and uh
so childhood after after the adoption
was
okay i guess but uh
suffered a lot of uh
[Music]
trauma like
with the separation and [ __ ]
um
like uh
uh how do you say um
um
you're missing being with your dad yeah
yeah yeah like you're having no memory
of it at all i wasn't told i was adopted
until i was 13.
so like there was that whole thing where
like when i was finally told i was
adopted it's like
i completely rebelled and like
completely went against everything you
you didn't know that you were done no i
didn't because it was so young yeah but
you said you sensed i have no memory of
my parents at all
no memory of my mom nobody remembers the
sound of her voice but when you found
out it made sense when i found out i
still didn't have i still didn't know
anything i didn't mean my dad until i
was 21.
um when i when i found him on he found
he actually found us on facebook
and uh he invited me to come live with
him back in austin we moved up to
connecticut when i was adopted uh when i
was eight we moved to connecticut from
texas and that's where she got the edna
job and all that
um
i mean i went through every uh school or
school grade like i graduated high
school [ __ ]
but
12 when i 12 i started like
12 is when i finally like
felt like
like there was something wrong here
and i i started experimenting with uh
with pills and all that and drinking and
then i started smoking pot at 14
cigarettes at 14 [ __ ]
[Music]
and everything else came after that and
uh but i guess like
when i was six i started riding bikes
uh bmx bikes as an escape and making
music and [ __ ] so i was actually one of
the youngest kids to ever be sponsored
for bmx um
one of the youngest kids ever [ __ ]
being the x games for bmx uh been in x
games twice and detour once
the youngest person that ever first
person and youngest person to ever do a
triple backflip on a bmx bike
um
you know all that
in high school was just
i didn't really
go to school but i still ended up
graduating with all my credits somehow
um
i don't know just
typical black sheep yeah like
what is your you had a brother i had a
brother yeah uh we we really don't have
a relationship at all
um
even though we came from the same fam
the same you know blood and everything
but is he different than you could work
polar opposites
uh he's actually like
a
good goody tissues the same same
biological parents yeah he doesn't do
drugs none of that like
he's actually he actually went to
college and he did all that like
eagle scout [ __ ]
honors all that [ __ ] really do you feel
like it's a genetic thing that you
inherited from your yeah definitely me
and my father are literally the same
[ __ ] person
it's interesting yeah
so you've been homeless now for how long
um
since i was like 14
how would you know 27 my seven yeah do
you have kids no no kids
you've been in love before
yep
i've been engaged
and that
complete [ __ ]
the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
basically
tore my heart out and [ __ ] did
everything she said she wasn't gonna do
you know it was basically
stereotypical [ __ ]
uh
romeo juliet i guess
and living
you're homeless and i was living in a
tent
uh well no right now i'm in project room
key oh so you got a roof over your head
yeah i'm in a
uh high end gardens hotel yeah but they
put you they got you off the uh
from from from being on the street yeah
yeah my ex actually uh she was my
girlfriend at the time she got me into
her room at the uh the gardens
and uh so you're on the streets in
hollywood yeah
came out here to hollywood five years
ago
from texas uh for drug treatment you
know i wanted to clean and all that and
see where that got me yeah what is your
drug today uh heroin fentanyl
you vote
several times
i probably hold the record for most ogs
180 in one year 180 yeah at least
wow yeah
you
are you still oding to this no no no no
no i haven't eaten
probably two years your body is probably
well no used to it yeah about two years
actually
yeah two years your body gets used to
yeah i've grown i'm gaining a severe
tolerance yeah uh-huh
did you still get high from it
i mean you just get well from it yeah
yeah yeah it's like i'm chasing the high
that i can't get anymore you know
do you do you think there's any
fix for your situation i mean not not
that it needs to be fixed maybe i'm
maybe maybe it's something you're cool
with um i'm not cool with it actually i
hate it i really want out of it
but i guess i'm in too deep now like it
just seems like it's in your dna yeah
this is just the life i was meant to
live
do you have hope of uh yeah i have hope
but i
hope
that i'll get better not
you know
not that i'm gonna get off the drugs
yes it's it's maybe too too far reached
yeah you're gonna get clean and that's
way too far out of the picture to even
get a job insurance agency yeah it's
just not gonna happen yeah
but some form of
living that's a little healthier maybe
yeah
definitely it'll be nice
yeah uh my girl got her she got her
section eight housing approved and all
that so uh
we'll be getting an apartment pretty
soon and all that
so that's cool i guess yeah
even you've been living like this for a
while what's the
you probably have got some interesting
stories living on the streets in
hollywood yeah
i could tell you a couple things what
kind of stuff has happened to you um
or have you seen okay well um martin
sheen actually
um me and my homeboy were uh we were
shooting up mess in the cubby hole uh on
hollywood highland boulevard uh highland
uh
yeah hollywood island and uh
martin sheen walked past this as we were
[ __ ] doing our shots smart machine
martin sheen yeah the dad yeah and he
just looked at us and he
like seen what we were doing and he just
walked past us and he's called the
squeakers
and so that was pretty funny
yeah that was like that was my actual
first celebrity encounter in hollywood
i'm getting called a tweaker yeah i can
call it speaker by martin sheen at least
i'm not charlie you know
not as bad as his son
what would you call success
just being happy
that's all i want i just want to be
happy
have you been moments where you've been
happy just been moments yeah but very
short-lived
i was happy when i was with my
girlfriend for
two years but then you know the setting
all kind of [ __ ] that all up
you know she won't get back with me
until i get off fentanyl but i'm
probably never going to get off the
setting all so
do you consider yourself
self-destructive extremely yeah
extremely
like it's something
you run into like this is like like that
that's my natural reaction to everything
you know it's like like
it's all i've known in my entire life so
that's all you know what to do you know
like i go to drugs like
anything happens in my life i go to
drugs like
and the woman who adopted you i mean she
would you consider her a good parent no
no terrible mother was it right she was
never home
[ __ ]
she she barely [ __ ] supports us
barely supports me she supports my
brother like full-fledged 100 but she
doesn't do [ __ ] for me she actually
doesn't want to do with me i've spoken
to her since i've been here so
do you feel misunderstood by most people
yeah very much so
what do you think people don't see when
they look at you
they're good in me mm-hmm i'm actually
really [ __ ] a good person i'm [ __ ]
cute sweetheart i'm i'm really not like
stereotypical drug addicts that
i i'm actually like
i'm a really good [ __ ] person i have
a huge heart like i'm really caring and
[ __ ] understanding
you know i i
i see the good in everybody else that
nobody sees in me i guess and i give
everybody the benefit of the doubt
so
do you think that the way you style
yourself the mohawk and the tattoos and
the piercings and all that kind of stuff
i think it kind of throws people off a
little bit
but do you think you do that on purpose
just maybe test people
maybe
probably a little bit yeah
and somebody really needs to make an
effort
to uh
to get through somebody did for a little
while
and then
you know my drug use kind of [ __ ] it
up
like i did my [ __ ] bicycle career
i could do a music career right
do you feel like some
interest some
some some
something like your motorcycle your
bicycle bicycle
writing and or your uh music might
pull you away from the streets and the
drugs and all that
um i hope so maybe you do a healthier
lifestyle i hope so one day i hope to
get sponsored
again um
[Music]
but you know until then i'm just
going through the motions you know have
you tried to get clean i tried yeah
but
like i said it's just not for me
silver life is just not for me i can't
can't do it
what kind of kid were you back in high
pretty much the same as i am now
but
younger and stupider
you're wise enough as you get older yeah
definitely
you still talk is your dad around still
yeah i talk to my dad all the time
my dad's my homeboy my dad's my [ __ ] i
love that dude he understands you yeah
that's great you're the exact same
[ __ ] person
he has hope for you uh oh yeah where's
your where's your dad at today he's in
he's back home still he's feeling
awesome he's still using yeah
he's a method though but you know so
like kind of like on opposite spectrums
with that whereas i'm down in person
he's another person but we're still
still got that mutual understanding you
know so
trippy's an interesting name how did you
get the name trippy
um okay well my real name is travis um
but trippy or
tribute was gained when i was about
17 i think 16 17.
i stood a lot of acid back in high
school
a lot of acid back in high school
and basically uh
how i got the name trippy specifically
is uh
me and my buddy were walking around town
uh glastonbury connecticut uh tripping
our nuts off on acid
and i was just
like the whole trip i was walking and i
was all i was saying was trip chippy
trippy trip
and he couldn't remember my real name so
he just started calling me trippy and it
stuck
and now you're trophy
what do you worry about what are you
afraid of
death
dying and
not coming back yeah
but then you've odd so many times you're
you're you're pushing what's
yeah
you're seeing what you can get away with
maybe
or getting close to what you testing the
limits yeah
what's your favorite memory
meeting my dad hmm
that must've been great yeah
it was pretty great
i lived with him for 10 months before i
came out here
did some of the pieces of the puzzle
start to fit when you met him all of
them did
everything made sense i have i'm
actually the oldest of five
i have three half siblings one of them
one of them was uh
only
able to live for about four months
and then died um but the other two my
dad had custody of them
uh finally after
after years and years and years of
trying to get custody from them him and
uh him and his wife finally got custody
of my brother and sister
so i i have yet to meet them but
hopefully when i go decide to go back
home i'll i'll have that chance
that's great and that's probably gonna
be the the
the eye-opening experience that i need
meeting
you know my my baby siblings
so i can finally have the opportunity to
be the big brother that i'm
supposed to be all alone yes
it must have been interesting for you to
go from never connecting with your dad
and wondering why you're like this maybe
oh it's crazy and then seeing that and
like oh now i see yeah
yeah just the way the way we talk the
way we walk is exactly the same like
we're like we've been so closely
identically looking like i like i'm
literally like his shadow like it's
ridiculous that's great yeah it's cool
do you have any regrets
several
probably more than i can count
probably more than i want to count
anything in particular stanza
getting involved in drugs in the first
place
i definitely regret that because
wouldn't be
here right now
but i feel at the same time that
i
i i
was like it was meant for me to
experience
you know
to gain the experience you know
do you feel like the addiction kind of
steps on your creativity
yeah
yeah definitely it might enhance it for
a while but then it yeah ultimately yeah
ultimately it
will lead to my downfall yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned
[Music]
everything in moderation
it's a good one
that's a good one
all right trippy thank you so much for
sharing your story of course i wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you
very much
you